markets regarding connections in
Hollywood of a quote here I don't know
who said it
connections are good but nobody is going
to put their business in jeopardy
because of a connection that's
absolutely true did you say no okay who
knows well wait did i okay
no I didn't it's true though okay it's
it's a business especially now and it's
become a very risk adverse business
especially now because people don't like
going to the movie theater unless
spider-man's there so Studios mm-hmm
they're spending the money where the
money's gonna get spent so you can know
Lorenzo
they've been been of internal who runs
or one of the guys who runs Warner
Brothers and you give me like hey man I
know you're doing a lot of stuff right
now I got this musical about socks the
retinol is probably gonna say you keep
that to yourself I mean it's a business
and and it's shifting like daily
especially now if all the streaming more
is going on and they're vise pissed at
Netflix it's pulling their content off
of Netflix start their own streamers and
they're trying to brand themselves like
this is what we do this is what we don't
do and other people are like counter
branding against that to get their own
it's a lot of money at stake it's a lot
of it's business like if what you do
lines up with their business model cool
doesn't mean you're not talented doesn't
mean what you do isn't great means it
doesn't fit them just had a pitch
meeting
that went amazing that's a major cable
ER and executives were totally into what
we had done it like this is really funny
and it's timely great but they're
rebranding and their brand is this and
my show is this so they're like it's
great the writing's rate it's gonna be a
fun show it's not for us and that's fine
you know because everybody is doing what
they need to do for their business I
don't advocate doing or changing your
stuff to fit somebody's business but it
doesn't hurt I don't think to sort of
pay attention to what networks studios
cable errs streamers what are they doing
and what do I have in my arsenal where
does it fit where does this make sense
you know what I mean
because you're in a business to your
business is getting your brand out there
and there's somewhere for every brand
you've got a brand they've got a brand
step fine brand links up so that's my
very long-winded answer to that question
so when someone says well now I'm mad
because person B won't help me get to
person a and they're just trying to hold
me down and and it's just this
industry's no good everybody's trying is
that really it or is it just like look
we all have our own sort of name and
reputation at stake I'd love to help you
but for that person yes that's true
because they've made a decision to see
it that way
so for them it's true absolutely true
the great thing about being a human
being with a brain is you get to decide
how you see things you get to choose how
you react to what happens to you so you
can decide well this sucks it's never
gonna happen everybody sucks when you
take a script and put it in a box put it
under your bed walk around be mad or you
can say all right well those are two
people in an industry with thousands of
people and somehow my work made me a
friend which means it probably will make
me another friend so I guess what I need
to do is keep going and find another
spot another Avenue another outlet
another way to get this material that I
believe in into the right hands the
right hands is super important because
it's not about just getting the things
set up or getting the things sold you
can get the things set up and get the
things sold and if it's in the wrong
hands it's gonna be crap you know you
need to be able to lock in with whoever
is going to be working with you to bring
the thing efficient that's what makes a
film or a show great because everybody
for the most part gets on the same page
I mean there's always disagreements and
well I think this should happen I think
this character should be here not there
that's it's just part of it but the
overall goal is the same that's what you
want
so if person B cannot take you to person
a or will not take you to person a
it's not the right fit there's a good
fit it's out there it's just not this
person and this person might be a better
fit for that other thing you got so make
sure you got another thing like I tell
the writers all the time
like if you want to get cooking
and you've got a script you dig that's
awesome you should never stop believing
in it
but you should have something else
because again brands people could be
like I'm not into this but I like the
writing what else you got
and then if you don't have anything else
you're sitting there gonna remember the
attention span it's really short so if
you can't come back and say oh yeah I
got another thing why don't we talk next
week about the new thing people forget
people see a lot of people especially
executives oh my god the scripts that
they read the pitches they have to see
all of it
continual stuff coming at them it's very
very rare for those guys to remember
this one specific thing that I saw three
months ago they can it happens if it
really stood out to that one person or
whatever but you know better your eyes
just keep making content you know it's
important I
you